[Music]
hello and welcome to this debate
from newton to darwin and einstein
scientists have presented their theories
as uncovering the true nature of the
world
yet one of the most central theories
quantum mechanics seems to make this
impossible
its founding father heisenberg concluded
that science was not able to describe
reality
today in many different fields
scientists refer to their theories as
models rather than descriptions of
reality
yet still promote the public image that
they are uncovering how things
ultimately are
is it time to jettison the idea that
science is uncovering the ultimate form
of the universe
or is it essential to the scientific
project to maintain the dream of
discovering the very nature of reality
once and for all i'm delighted to
introduce our three
speakers for this debate the
first is claudio duran who's
professor of theoretical physics physics
at imperial college
then we have hillary lawson who's a
post-post-modern philosopher philosopher
and renowned critic of philosophical
realism
best known for his theory of closure and
sundar sarakai
who is founder director of the manipole
center for philosophy and humanities
and author of books such as indian
philosophy and the philosophy of science
well before we go to the debate
proper we'd ask the panelists to present
their
opening positions addressing the
question
was heisenberg right is science unable
to describe reality
um i'd like to ask you to begin please
claudia so
there's probably a lot of very deep
elements in this
debate i will go through it but first of
all let me just give you my position
which is important to remember that
i think it's prominent right now
important to bear in mind that even if a
fundamental truth did exist
the way we understand it the way we
experience it
the way we'll adapt to it has always
been
through the past history and in the
future will be
evolving and getting more precise even
more polished and accurate
i think there's many layers in our
understanding
of the nature of reality probably an
infinite number of
of them and we have the opportunity to
reassess
ourselves and ask ourselves the
questions at every single step of the
way
through other points being raised on
whether or not there's exists a
fundamental truth to be uncovered
how we should present it how we should
present it to the public
it was starting with heisenberg's
statement and the connection of whether
or not science
will be able to describe a fundamental
nature of reality
let me just point out that the
uncertainty that exists in heisenberg
and certain
principle is not so much about an
uncertainty in the lack of determinism
in our laws of physics and nature in
general
it's really pointing out a lack of
determinism
in some of the microscopy observables
and those two are extremely different
so if i may just to put things a little
bit in context for those of you not
necessarily familiar with
heisenberg uncertainty in principle we
know that it's a fundamental law
of nature of quantum physics but really
of nature
as a whole that in general at
the very microscopic level one can never
determine
every observable with an infinite
precision
we know that to be the case for instance
for position and velocities
we know that if we know your position
with an infinite precision you won't be
able to determine your speed with an
infinite precision
no matter which apparatus you're using
this is just a failure in being able to
describe
all the quantities about a system all
the observables
however this uncertainty making
measurements in quantum mechanics
should not be confused with
uncertainties in how
us ourselves describe and understand
nature
so the understanding in determining the
value of an observable in quantum
mechanics
is very different to arguing that our
understanding
of the nature of reality can never
become ever more precise
and closer to the truth um so to
reiterate this point in heisenberg and
certainly in principle
it is not in contradiction with the fact
that quantum mechanics
and science in general is very much
deterministic and we can get ever closer
to our truth
in heisenberg assertive principle the
uncertainty again is not about a lack of
determinism
in the very laws of physics in our very
understanding of the universe it's a
lack of in
determinism in the macroscopical
observable
so to my point of view there's no reason
to believe that we cannot get ever
closer
and more precise in our description of
nature and possibly
towards a fundamental truth hillary
i i imagine you have a slightly
different view over to you yeah
thank you james so um
well you referred to heisenberg of
course he was amongst the most
influential scientists of the 20th
century
and his account of quantum mechanics the
copenhagen interpretation
is the model that he generally used to
understand particle physics and
therefore
the building blocks of matter but he was
also a philosopher
he wrote a book uh physics and
philosophy which laid out his views not
only about the philosophy of
quantum mechanics but the philosophy of
uh
more broadly including the history of
philosophy and in it he argues that
quantum mechanics has shown that exact
science
is possible without what uh he describes
as the assumption of metaphysical
realism
by which he means that the theories of
science do describe
some existent things out there
and he goes on to say that in quantum
mechanics and i quote
objective reality has evaporated
now strangely you might think um
his philosophical work has not been
widely covered by
uh philosophers and but on a little bit
of reflection
maybe it's not so strange when he was
initially writing
um philosophy certainly in
britain and north america was largely
the mainstream
would have held a sort of scientific
view that is on two fronts on the one
hand thinking that
philosophy was there to support and
provide the bedrock
for for science and a second thought
that
i'd really like philosophy to be a
science itself and be making
um gradual and consistent progress
towards the truth
and so obviously the idea that one of
the most leading
scientists was challenging the thought
that theories could actually describe
uh the world in some ultimate way was
didn't go down you know totally well
now i want to concur with heisenberger
and
and go a little bit further now as a as
a post-realist
uh i am a critic of
of realism and the idea that we can
provide a definitive account of an
objective reality
uh but sometimes i misunderstood when
when putting forward this view i'm not
arguing that
uh there isn't stuff out there that's
independent of us
and i'm certainly not arguing that we
just make up anything in our heads and
we create it
and and so forth but what i
am wanting to argue is the language and
indeed the theories of science
provide metaphors or models which enable
us to intervene in the world they are
tools
to enable us to get things to happen
they're not descriptions of some things
that are ultimately out there because
we've got no means
of actually reaching out to those things
um and so uh i think we can refine those
metaphors or in a more technical sense i
refer to them as closures
we can refine those closures and get
them to work
more effectively but i don't think we
get any closer
to somehow touching an objective reality
of actually being able to describe it
and some of you may feel that
you're a little uncomfortable with this
you don't really want to give up the
idea that we know where we are
that we've we've got some sort of
framework and and to somehow head into a
world where we've got lots of competing
models feels a bit um
a bit uncomfortable so i think it's not
really quite like that
the frameworks that we've got to
understand the world at the moment
are very powerful and very effective um
but like all other stages in human
history at some point in the future they
will all be abandoned
in favor of alternative accounts and so
you can have a fantasy that your current
uh metaphors of the world will be
held forever but it's never happened
before and i'm going to
i'm proposing it's never going to happen
uh in the future either
and instead think of these
these this account of the world in terms
of metaphors and closure
as providing a world of potential
that instead of thinking well we've
we've arrived and we we've got an
account which is the one
count instead it enables us to think
there's an indefinite number of
alternative models
that we could adopt and those might
enable us to intervene differently and
hopefully better than we do at the
moment
and create a world that is both better
for ourselves
and hopefully others as well
yeah i think you know what hillary said
i want to pick up
a couple of points from that it's a good
start
to this particular question to begin
with heisenberg
because as hillary mentioned heisenberg
doesn't seem to be very popular with the
philosophers
who have not taken some of his work
seriously in terms of philosophy
but i want to alert us to the other book
which came out much
later now after the physics and
philosophy it's called reality and it's
order
and it is a very interesting essay a
long essay it's a small book
uh which was translated much later as he
said
and i think there we can really discover
the kinds of questions on the meaning of
reality
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you